again try try to understand like you
can't just repeat a thrill and then
magically it's going to make you more
skilled at the technical aspects like I
guess you could lift that way right so
you you lift and then you get stronger
you just repeat the lift over and over
okay or you maintain strength but
technical skills not like that so you
have a drill and the purpose of the
drill is that you can you you understand
that
I'm only as good as much as I'm doing
the drill like that's the bare minimum
okay so instead of doing this technique
and I go here and then he's there and
then I go WR and you start timing uh how
much I'm doing so we do one rep okay do
one rep boom boom boom okay that's the
one rep and now I set up again well all
this set up time is taken away from my
rep time got so we combine the the stuff
all right but it doesn't make it any
less a technical drill so as we get rid
of the setup time to increase the rep
count over time I still want to be as
technical as
possible just because I got rid of the
setup time I'm I don't start working
[Applause]
crap you get it all right so what am I
working on the same stuff I'm I'm always
working on so we want these weapons to
stick that's what makes them I weapons
so they have to stick how do they stick
they're going to rotate crosses that's
how they stick the yin and yang AIS are
are going to rotate around to prevent
the The Clash from happening
okay so so right here I rotate
around I
don't I don't come this way I don't go
that way the pressure that he has there
I yield to it and go around it boom
pressure there's no pressure here this
is where I draw back on
ATT
boom
around
and it doesn't change on the
sword
so because I don't let him hit
me I see connection and
around
same thing here he goes around I go
around come
on
not like this
go I'm
stu okay let's
go
so remember we're trying to make our way
we're trying to bridge our way to
application timing moving away from the
embryonic timing okay so I'm here I
don't want I don't have to do this
anymore in the drill okay I I what I
want to do instead is take the body
relationship of application
timing so as I go and he moves you see
how I move with him he moved I move with
him I'm not over here he goes and then I
move on the weapon the guy's flanking
you you need to keep the center line so
as I he goes I move you see that I do
that every time you see every time he
mov I've already started
moving so now look at my Center Line to
his Center Line and it stays the same
every
time but it so that you're not here
he goes and then he has to wait and then
I go that's just we're keeping that huge
stepping stone to the application time
okay it's Center to Center I move he
move I move okay try it
again all right so it's not it's because
the drill has a reset to to increase rep
count over time you got to kind of gain
this but it's better to to get a higher
rep count over time and
approximate an application timing
okay um but because of the reset it's
not necessarily the best way to address
an application timey of makos okay but
the the concepts are going to be the
same don't contest rotate the cross and
get back in there okay but what I'm
going to do is something in between
application timing and EMB IC time okay
so everything's the same it go around
and okay I'm just
[Music]
here you can see that I'm wait I'm kind
of waiting there but I don't I don't now
let the cross manifest you get it but
the ukemi is exactly the same at least
conceptually where your hand is in space
and where it is in the cut that stuff
changes okay and again it's not that I'm
going fast it's just that I
boom you got to get out of
[Music]
the okay let's
try